[Música]
bienvenidos al programa de medio
ambiente de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle los indígenas
gobernando sus propios territorios y
protegiendo la selva amazónica esa es la
idea que impulsan desde hace años 14
territorios indígenas en la amazonía
colombiana con el acompañamiento de la
fundación gaia amazonas este proyecto
único en el mundo pretende que las
etnias puedan manejar los recursos
financieros tener una relación directa
con el estado y mandar en sus tierras
según su cosmogonía es que esos
territorios de los departamentos de
amazonas vaupés guainía no están
constituidos como municipios en otras
palabras aunque hacen parte de colombia
no están reglados por la división
administrativa y ante ese vacío los
indígenas proponen gobernar sus tierras
lo que podría influir en la protección
ambiental de uno de los pulmones verdes
del mundo los 14 territorios representan
el 24 por ciento de toda la selva
amazónica colombiana con un total de 94
millones de hectáreas donde habitan 51
pueblos indígenas como los huitoto los
tucano o los bara sanos y gracias a su
protección el 95% de los bosques de
estas zonas están conservados además
allí hay 2.000 kilómetros cuadrados de
bosques y ríos que comparten fronteras
con brasil venezuela y perú por eso juan
carlos preciado asesor jurídico de la
fundación gaia amazonas apunta que una
de las importancias ambientales de estos
territorios son los corredores de fauna
que llegan incluso a otros países como
lo explicó aquí en france24
importancia grandísima estamos hablando
de territorios como apaporis que
garantizan la conectividad entre esa
cuenca del caquetá y la del río negro
incluso a vapor inspira tics ya está la
iglesia conectividad
el territorios
como los de los que están en la zona del
río putumayo en el departamento amazonas
que tienen una gran importancia para
mantener el equilibrio ambiental sobre
el río putumayo y para generar si en el
perú hay buenas políticas una
conectividad también binacional ya
estamos hablando de algo muy importante
para el mundo para ese país y para este
país porque es el agua de este país pero
para el mundo también porque es la
conservación de la amazonía para el
indígena de ulm y para gobernar sus
territorios implica continuar una
protección ancestral que han hecho en la
selva
de esos recursos naturales minerales
vegetales forman parte de nosotros
porque eran seres como nosotros en la
primera generación que desobedecieron a
nuestro padre creador y por eso ellos
están allá porque nuestro padre creador
los castigó y ellos desde dónde están
ellos están cumpliendo una función muy
importante para la pervivencia de la
humanidad entonces nosotros desde
nuestros principios culturales los
mantenemos y más que todo conservando
porque incluso muchos estados están
diciendo que nosotros los pueblos
indígenas formamos parte de ese de
esos
latifundistas no nosotros cuidamos los
bosques es para que la humanidad siga
perviviendo mire el servicio que le
estamos dando al mundo entero es que
sigamos respirando aire puro en todo el
mundo y la protección de la que habla de
ulm y para está avalada por el estado al
menos en el papel en 2018 el entonces
gobierno de juan manuel santos firmó el
decreto 632 que establecía las normas
para que los indígenas pudieran gobernar
esas zonas no municipalizadas
hasta enero de 2020 siete territorios
étnicos prepararon toda la documentación
sobre los límites geográficos y cómo
gobernarían allí y con ello le
solicitaron al ministerio del interior
que formalizará su control territorial
el mismo que ya estaba protegido por el
decreto
pero nada de esto se ha hecho realidad
juan carlos preciado cree que es por
falta de voluntad política el decreto
tiene un asunto bien importante y es que
los pueblos indígenas son los que
proponen son los que hacen el trabajo y
le dicen algo de lo venga y nos sentamos
a conversar a partir de esa propuesta
y los indígenas lo están haciendo lo que
hay falta de voluntad voluntad y
decisión de cumplir lo que dice la ley
porque porque el decreto tiene tiempos
precisos ahí se faltaron unos tiempos
cuántos días hay para una respuesta
cuántos días para hacer todo
y en ese en esa temporalidad que es
corta para facilitar para agilizar algo
que lleva 30 años detenido
pues hemos gastado de un algo que
debería tener alrededor de 40 días dos
años antes de esta demora los 14
territorios indígenas le elevaron una
petición al próximo presidente que
elegir a colombia para que de una vez
por todas implemente una normatividad
que ya estaba acordada y así incentivar
la protección de la amazonía de mano de
los pueblos ancestrales pues como dice
teúl mí para ellos ya están cumpliendo
su papel
nosotros estamos haciendo nuestro papel
que nos corresponde estamos conservando
pero las otras sociedades no lo están
haciendo no están cumpliendo pero
entonces nosotros si nos gustaría es de
qué
se busquen esas canales de cómo
contribuir económicamente para que
nuestros procesos indígenas que
efectivamente hace falta mucho por
construir visibilidad y visibilizar al
mismo estado como estamos construyendo
nuestro proceso y es lo que hemos
carecido muchos de esos recursos
financieros para nosotros seguirnos
organizando en esa con esa visión de
garantizar esa pervivencia juan carlos
preciado agrega que el trabajo debe ser
de la mano del estado para proteger a la
amazonía colombiana
para garantizar que el extractivismo no
entre se requiere ese ejercicio de
coordinación con el resto del aparato
estatal en términos de gobiernos
indígenas gobierno nacional y gobiernos
departamentales quizás que trabajan de
manera conjunta de manera armónica a
partir de que de la visión de desarrollo
expresada en los planes de vida de los
pueblos indígenas ese es el punto de
partida que eso sí cumple con este
llamado terminamos nuestra crónica de
medio ambiente vean este y otros
programas en france24 punto com hasta la
próxima
[Música]